- [Interviewer] All right, Latoya.
- Yes?
- [Interviewer] Latoya
where'd you grow up,
where are you from?
- [Latoya] Watts.
- [Interviewer] Watts, South central L.A.?
- [Latoya] Yes.
- [Interviewer] And tell
me about your family.
Did you have both your parents growing up?
- Sorta, my mom was like a drug addict
and she had different men
in and out of the house,
I never knew who my dad was.
- [Interviewer] Okay, and
how was your childhood?
Any abuse?
- Bad, yeah, when I was six years old,
my step dad raped me and I had one hole
from my vagina to my butt.
(sobbing) 42 stitches
and I was six years old.
- [Interviewer] You were six years old?
- Six years old my step dad raped me
and I had one hole from
my vagina to my butt.
I had 42 stitches at six years old.
I couldn't walk, I couldn't go to school.
And they made me lie, you know,
you can manipulate a child's mind.
So they made me lie and say,
"Tell your mom you got a whoopin'."
"Tell your mom you got in trouble."
They told me what to tell
her that I was in trouble.
I was a kid, I believed them.
You know what I'm sayin'?
So, I believed what
they said, I was a kid.
I believed them.
And my mom had seven children
with seven different daddies.
So we had different men in and out.
So all I know now is prostitute, dope,
and that's all I know 'cause
it's what I grew up around.
I don't know nothin' else.
- [Interviewer] When did you leave home
and go out on your own?
- At 12.
- [Interviewer] 12!
- Yeah, my stepdad was
always molesting me,
always sucking on my breasts.
When I was in the third
grade I had one big breast
and one small one because
he sucked on the big one.
And I had one nipple.
And my mom's like, "What's that?"
It was the one that was sticking out
because he was sucking on it.
I was in third grade.
All my life I been abused,
molested, around drugs.
That's why now, I thought I'd be good
because I don't want my
kids to grow like that.
- [Interviewer] You have kids?
- Two, they're 18 years old.
Boy and a girl, they're twins.
- [Interviewer] And did you raise them?
- No I didn't raise them.
I don't know how to raise
a kid, I wasn't raised.
- [Interviewer] Where are your children?
- In Hawthorne, with their dad.
- [Interviewer] With dad?
- Yeah.
They love me, but I just,
see, it's like this;
I've been abused all my
life, so, is it my fault that
I don't know how to treat them?
I don't know what to
do about it (sobbing).
I've been abused so much in my life
that's why I can't keep no man
because I just been abused
all my life to where
I push everybody away
that tell me they love me.
Because I don't know how
to be loved, I don't know
how to love.
So when I'm bitter and angry at everybody
it's not nobody's fault.
So, I've got to grow up and get a life
and get over it but it's hard.
All I know is dope, sucking dick,
fucking, asshole and all that.
It's all I know how to do
because that's the way my mom do.
Seven different daddies,
seven different kids?
That don't make no sense.
My step dad molesting me,
I tell her, she don't believe me.
It's ridiculous, totally ridiculous.
It don't make sense for a
mom to do you like that.
You know, my mom she didn't
believe me, my grandmother?
She was ride or die, she was there for me.
My grandmother was ride or die.
- [Interviewer] She was what?
- My grandmother.
- [Interviewer] Oh, I see, ride or die?
- She was ride or die. She believed me.
I tell her what happened, she believed me.
She did not hesitate, none of that.
- [Interviewer] Your
grandmother saved you?
- My grandmother was a ride or die chick.
I loved that lady until
she died at 71 years old.
She was blind.
The worst day of my life, yeah.
I hate my mom to this day.
All I wanted was her to take care of me.
She didn't pamper me.
She let my stepdad molest me.
She was always on heroin
and crack and all that shit.
She was mean to her kids
to get what she wanted.
I'm her only daughter.
It's not fair. I didn't asked to be born.
I didn't ask to be born.
So, I'm down here around people,
trying to see if I can do
people, but I don't do people.
I don't fucking, I don't like people.
I've been hurt so many times by people.
Molested, raped, gagged,
choked, kidnapped.
My dad's friends, my step
dad's friends, took his finger
up my vagina at three and shit
like that, that's not right.
I was destroyed before I even grew.
I been destroyed my whole life.
It's not my fault but I try.
You gotta try to get over it.
It's hard to get over shit like that.
I don't like my breast touched,
I don't like my butt touched.
When I'm out there whoring, prostituting,
I lose a lot of money
because I don't like my breasts
touched, my butt touched.
I can't even get into a
car because I can't...
My mind goes back to where I actually see
my step dad molesting me.
It's hard.
- [Interviewer] It's like reliving it.
- It's hard, like if they
touch my breasts I go
No don't do that. Stop, don't do that.
Jumpy and then I get outta the car.
I lost a lot of money 'cause of that shit.
Don't do that! Stop, stop, move!
It hurt though. I Lost a
lot of money doing that.
Stop!
Not my butt! I lost a
lot of money doing that.
I just react, I can't help it.
- [Interviewer] So you lost
a lot of money doing that?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Because
you run out of the car?
- You know 'cause I jump,
when they touch my breasts,
when I give them head,
I'm like, "No! Stop!"
And that's it.
'Cause in my mind goes back
to my step dad raping me,
molesting me.
- [Interviewer] You started
using crack at what age?
- 17.
- My mom, look, when I was a kid, my mom,
she had like a bong and she smoked primo
and blew it out her mouth.
At 17 and I got hooked.
She used to, when I was a kid,
she used to put beer in my bottle.
Beer in my bottle.
I didn't like milk when I was a baby,
I liked beer in my bottle.
- [Interviewer] You drank
beer out of a baby bottle?
- I didn't like milk, I liked beer.
I used to cry for beer when I was a baby.
I used to cry for fucking beer.
My mom used to give me
beer in a bottle, not milk.
I was crying for beer.
I wanted beer. I wanted beer in a bottle.
- [Interviewer] This is at what age?
- Beer? I was baby, like
six, seven, eight, months.
Nine months, drinking
beer out of a bottle.
Not milk, beer.
My mom would give apple
juice, so I go for my bottle
the juice, I'd get mad and throw
it because it was not beer.
So I'm trying to find beer and my mom...
Man, I don't wanna talk no more.
It's just sad.
- [Interviewer] When you were a young girl
did you have dreams of
doing anything else in life?
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Interviewer] Like what?
- An artist, I can draw real good.
A dancer, I dance.
Like on TV like, my friends though?
I had no fucking friends.
When I was a kid I had
dreams like of a big house,
my husband, a mansion,
that was my dream life.
My life wasn't gonna be no shit like this.
I think I'm still dreaming now.
For real, I swear, I
think I'm still dreaming.
This is not my life, I'm dreaming.
Am I dreaming or not?
If it's a dream, (sobbing)
I don't care what anybody
says, I'm dreamin'.
This a dream, this is not real.
This never happened to me, I'm dreamin'.
This is not real, right
now I'm talking to you,
this is a dream, you're in
my dream, this not real.
This is not my fuckin' life
being down here like this.
My life has a husband,
two car garage, a job.
This is a dream!
One day I'll wake up from this
dream and I'll be in reality.
I'm asleep right now in a dream.
This is not real, it can't be.
I don't deserve this, I was
a good daughter (sobbing).
- [Interviewer] How do
you think all these years
of living this lifestyle has changed you?
- It hasn't, I'm still the same way.
- [Interviewer] You were this
way since you were young?
- Yeah, I'm not ashamed.
- [Interviewer] You
never saw another life?
- No, I don't know
nothing but suckin' dick,
fucking, ass, selling for
crack, I've done it all,
That's all I know.
I don't have to have a
man in my life to survive.
My mom had seven kids, seven daddies.
My dad is my first cousin.
My mom and dad are cousins.
My mom and dad are first cousins.
Back in Louisiana, back in those days,
they said incest was the best.
No, no, that ain't gonna
do the kids no good.
Incest is not the best, that's fucked up.
That's just scandalous, that's not right.
My mom said, "Do what
I say not what I do."
We see everything you
do mom, how can you say,
"Do what I say not what I do."
Everything you do is right in my face.
Smoke primo, put the needle
right in her arm, get all drunk.
She'd be like, "Hey,
Toya, wash the dishes..."
Like that on heroin,
"Toya, go wash the clo..."
She'd said, "Go to the store,
get some bread, money..."
Fall like that, my mom dozing off.
- [Interviewer] How are
your kids doing today?
- In Hawthorne with their dad.
- [Interviewer] And they're okay?
- Yeah, they're okay.
I saw them one time the other day.
They like love me though.
I try.
I don't tell my kids nothing
bad about what my mom did to me
and that's all right, never.
'Cause I don't want them stressing.
I've never told my kids
nothing bad about my mom,
their grandmother.
She treats my kids good, like, real good.
I don't have enough to
get stuff for my kids,
I don't ask her, never, never.
Who would do it like that?
I don't do my mom like that.
I won't ever tell my kids
nothing bad about my mom
what she did to me,
never have, never will.
What happened to me,
they wouldn't believe it.
I said, "Oh grandma I
had this," I was smilin',
but inside, I mean, crumble.
Smilin' on the outside, inside, crushed.
My mom treated me like shit!
She'd sit on the toilet and sit on her ass
and I dint say shit (sobbing).
Why I don't know.
For nothing, for nothing, my mom hated me.
For nothing, for nothing, all for nothing.
I don't know why she do me
like that, I don't know.
(sobbing)
I don't want to talk
no more, I can't do it.
I don't want to talk no more.
- [Interviewer] Okay, Latoya.
Thank you so much for sharing your story.
- Napkin.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
(sobbing)
- I don't understand.
I've been through that,
I don't understand.
(indistinct)